here we have who working as senior data
engineer ining wood and here is going to
talk about self
service thank you so much U great uh hi
everyone my name is adya I'm here from
Robinhood I'm here to talk about self
service analytics using
llms so let's let's get started right
before we dive into the subject a little
bit about myself um as I mentioned
currently I'm working as a senior data
engineer at Robinhood
before this um I was working as a data
engineer at Facebook and I led a data
science team at a mental Healthcare
startup um besides work uh I enjoy
playing soccer if anyone gues I'm an
Arsenal
fan oh nice
okay okay I I was hoping better but okay
beyond beyond soccer um I also love
being involved in the open source
Community especially in terms of like
develop ments of llm and all the
ecosystem that we are building on open
source
llms um one quick disclaimer the
opinions in this talk are my and not my
employers so with that out of the way I
think we can get started um I'm very
happy to be here in terms of P data I've
been a long time listener but first time
presenter so let's get
started uh we have a lot to cover today
right we we are going to quickly go
through self-service analytics what what
does that even mean right why do we need
it what are the challenges what's the
history there after that we'll start
with llms um I think at this point no
one is unfamiliar with llm everyone
knows what are llms but we'll still have
a quick introduction to that and then
we'll get into the meat of the talk
which is how do we use llms to build a
self-service platform and um we would
end it with some tips and tricks so if
you're already doing this we are already
building
an analytics platform using LMS how can
you make it better right and hopefully
at the end we'll have some time left for
Q&A I'm looking forward to all the
questions um so self-service analytics
right what what exactly is it is a
system for automated data analysis right
one might argue why why do we even need
it so the main reason for why we need
self-service analytics is people who are
taking the decisions you you can call
them stakeholders business or whatever
are very different from people who are
working in the data teams who know how
to maintain and build and analyze data
and this disconnect of like having two
teams sort of makes it necessary to have
a platform or have a tool where people
who are not very familiar with data can
get the data or information that they
are looking for so the objective is to
facilitate Swift data informed dision
right and reduce dependency on
Specialized teams and the challenges
here are we are in the realm of unknown
unknowns right so for even of the
simplest of businesses there are like
infinite data analysis request you can
always encounter new problems that would
need different sort of view of data and
different data analysis so essentially
we are trying to build a system with
infinite flexibility with finite
resources and that's like that's
impossible but even if we let's say we
were able to build that we were able to
build um a system with infinite
flexibility it is not set in store right
business is evolved so data keeps
changing and even if you somehow build
the system the system will need to
evolve with the business and
data so let's do a quick uh trip down
the memory link like what what has what
has been done in Self Service Analytics
so I would argue the first instance or
like the very first attempt at
self-service analytics were like report
Builders and um maybe not many in the
room including myself have dealt with
that a lot but essentially the idea was
to have U reports that are built
dynamically by end user an end user
could be technical non-technical
stakeholder or the someone from data
team and the idea seems uh interesting
but the reality of it is very difficult
right because once you start U start
with people who are not very aware of
the underlying data structures it is
very difficult for them to build
accurate reports all the sort of
assumptions that they make about data
that might not be true and uh it's also
not very flexible right like you might
not be able to build data across
different domains in your business so
the next Paradigm Shift was Dash
dashboards so if people remember
dashboards were going to be the Silver
Bullet where you build a dashboard for
one domain and you hand it to end users
and they can slice and dice data do
whatever they want and answer all their
questions but the sad reality of that is
that's not true right even dashboards do
cover a lot wider surface area than
reports they are not infinitely flexible
right you still need to update the
dashboard as your business evolves or if
you need to answer any questions which
are slightly different than what the
dashboard was built for the dashboard is
pretty much useless so the next
iteration in self-service analytics was
semantic layer and this is sort of my
least favorite one so the idea of
semantic layer is building a semantic
layer or a common language on top of
data which is understood by both
technical folks and non-technical folks
and the issue is I think this sort of is
a loose lose situation right because
people who are working with data they
already have their tools and they have a
thorough understanding of how to
interact with data they don't need to
learn a new language which sort of
arbitrarily uh divides the data into
metrics or Dimensions or have like this
sort of like Bumbo jumbo over data and
for business folks I think it's also a
steep learning go so they are they are
used to asking questions in plain
English and they they might actually in
some instances prefer something like SQL
which is like very structured we are
learning this something new language
which is not understood by either right
so this is sort of a my mic went up yeah
yeah so this is sort of a quick recap of
where we word with selfservice analytics
um so let's look at the reality right uh
the I think this meme sort of sums up
the reality real well because um if you
have worked or even if you have like
interacted with data team you can
validate that this is true the
dashboards become sort of the primary
goto for all the teams Technical
non-technical and the main priority of
data teams is to M maintain and make
sure the dashboards are working well and
while they are doing that any new s of
business questions or any new adhoc
analysis request they are just like
drowning with those all all those
analytic requests right and the
self-service analytic platform becomes a
long dead memory no one has like time to
work on it and no one is interested in
that and the reason why that's true is
it's pretty difficult to build a truly
selfer analytics platform right it's
difficult because of the technical
barriers difficult because of lack of
intuitive interface and it's a resource
intensive undertaking right so if you
are building something like this you you
want to be very sure that people are
going to use
this so let's go on a tangent here and
let's quickly look at large language
models so uh I almost already know the
answer to this questions but how many of
you have interacted with a large
language
model yep I'm I'm not at all surprised
everyone raised their hand so I I don't
think so large language models need a
huge introduction but is essentially
they are these AI models which are
designed to understand and generate
human language the way it is done is
they are trained on this huge Corpus of
data using a neural network architecture
called Transformers and it results in
this llm which not only understands the
human structure but it can generalize
well so what I mean by generalized way
it can be used in like General tasks of
like creating summary of coming up with
plans translating from one language to
other and you you must have been at some
point in your life you must have been
Amazed by the ability of Elms be it
writing poem poems about something or
translating some pseudo language into
real language or like just providing
very accurate
summary one um one novel use of llms not
even novel at this point is generating
code right and it makes sense if you
think about it code is nothing but a
language and essentially at the core of
U NLP you are translating a language
into other language right so you are
translating human instruction in code
and llms Excel at that so here we just
have like a simple example of if you
went into chart gbd and asked it to
implement quick sort it would be able to
do it without any difficulty but that's
not all even if you had a very propriety
piece of code and it is failing for some
bizarre reason I'm pretty sure if you
paste it in chart gbt using gbd4 you
will be able to troubleshoot it much
quicker than if you are going to do it
on your own so llms are not only great
at writing code but they're also great
at fixing the code and explaining you
why it's
broken and many people forget this but
SQL is nothing but a domain specific
programming language right so it's easy
for llms to convert natural instructions
into SQL right so again here's just a
quick example of if you had asked CH GPT
about um let's say customers U amount
spent by customers in first 30 days and
tell it uh what the tables are it can
come up with a pretty accurate query and
it doesn't stop here the quality or the
accuracy of the query increases when you
provide detailed in instructions with
the schema of the underlying tables
maybe some documentation and some column
or column profiles or information about
the underlying data so as you can see
text to SQL at this point is not even
novel use case many people are doing
this but we can take a pause and see
that what were the challenges in
building a self-service analytics the
main challenge was we were in the realm
of unknown unknown where when we were
building system we weren't sure how it
would be used what questions would be
asked to this system right and the
strengths of llms are to understand
parts and figure out what the user is
asking convert those sort of thoughts
into code and maybe execute that code so
essentially the challenges that were
building that were involved in building
a self-service Analytics tool are
covered by llms and this provides a
great opportunity in building
self-service analytics using llms so
what would be the flow of such system so
such system could start with a user
question so the question could be what
is our retention for last 30 days or how
is this new product that we launches
doing or what are the fraudulent
transactions and this question would be
interpreted by llm with its intent and
then it could be used to figure out what
is the actual source data that it needs
to vary in order to answer this question
and then it can come up with very
accurate SQL queries to run against the
database to retrieve the data and it
could also be used to generate let's say
python code to come up with a
visualization on top of this data and
provide it to end user so I would argue
that the a great analytic system in
future would have this simple UI where
you would have just a text box and you
you could ask it virtually anything
about your data and it would provide the
answers so let's see how such system
would look like right so this is a
simplified architecture of what an llm
based Self Service analytics system
would look like the main components here
are um there's something called as a
data catalog connector then we have
query generator we have database
connector and we have python code
generator let's quickly see how the flow
would be so the user again asks the
question using natural plain language
plain English and the system um passes
the question and figures out what would
be the source tables so this first part
would be carried by a data catalog
connector which can connect to your data
catalog and figure out what are the best
source tables to answer this question
once we have that we can move on to the
next component which would be a query
generator
and this component would take input as
the user question and Source tables
along with maybe some information about
schema and once we have this this
component can generate accurate queries
we can run those queries against the
database using the a simple database
connector and then we can generate final
python code which maybe plots this in a
intuative way for the end
user so let's start taking a look at all
these components one by one right so
what's the objective of having a data
catalog connector so ideally a data
catalog connector should be able to
connect to your repository with metadata
schema information and documentation and
given a question it should be able to
retrieve the source tables to answer
that
question so the workflow is very simple
as I mentioned it takes input of all the
things that you have in your data League
data warehouse or even a database and it
takes input as the user question and it
Returns the appropriate tables that
would be used to answer that question
and implementation here is so first the
data catalog depending on your company
size data size could be as simple as a
CSV file with table names and
descriptions or it could be as big as a
system like aan or data Hub where you
have all your documentation schema
information lineage everything at one
place
and U for smaller data catalogs if you
have let's say just a CSV file with
th000 rows or 5,000 rows you can you can
easily pass all that information to a
llm call in and the context lenses are
pretty big these days so you don't even
have to do anything else but let's say
if you are working on an Enterprise data
solution with tens of thousands of
tables and let's assume which is very
unrealistic but all of them have like
very very good documentation you could
use uh something similar to rag which is
retrieval augmented generation so it's
essentially a uh it's an interface on
top of all this unstructured data and it
will give you the actual tables which
answer the question right um for the
Simplicity I'm sticking with like chart
GPT screenshots but you can feel free to
visualize this as an llm API call or you
could have your own llm and it would
look very similar so what would be the
simplest implementation of this data
catalog uh connector right so
essentially you will have something like
this in a prompt where the red box is
all the information about your existing
data the blue box is the user question
and the green box is the output returned
by llm right and you can build tooling
around it to have it access all the
information have like intelligent
retries and stuff stuff and it would
give you the uh appropriate data
sources so let's move on to step two
right so we started with a user question
now we have what are the source tables
for answering this question so the next
component would be a query generator and
this component again is the the brain of
this component would be an llm the llm
could be any like open a gbd4 or falcon
or llama code Lama whatever you have it
and um the main purpose of this
component would be accepting user
question and the source schema and
returning a compiled query right a query
that runs and Returns the results so the
implementation as I mentioned could be
any llm and if you actually want to go
one step further you could start with
all your existing queries and find youe
an llm based on your proprietary data
and that would improve improve the
accuracy of the whole thing a lot
more so again uh sticking to chart GPD
screenshots as a implementation so the
implementation would be in the red box
we would have U the tables which are um
which are found by the data catalog
connector and we would have information
about the schema and the documentation
for those tables and then in the blue
box we would have the actual user
question
and the expected output here is the llm
will give you a SQL query which can
answer the question asked by the
user uh so next comes the sort of least
interesting component of this system
which is like a database connector and
this is not even anything new right like
we already have database connectors and
all the systems that interact with data
so it would be uh a simple python class
in this
which interacts with um the underlying
data infrastructure that you might have
and essentially it it just accepts a
query Returns the results preferably in
a python data object which can be used
further
Downstream um so let's move on to the
last last component of this system right
which is the python code code generator
and this is again very similar to VAR
generator where it would input it would
access input as a python object which
would be the data frame of the query
results and it would accept the user
question as another input and based on
these two it can come up with python
code to plot and visualize whatever the
user is asking so the implementation
would be again similar to what we have
seen before with the red box will have
the schema for the data frame which are
like um returned by the qu generator and
in the blue box we are still sticking to
the user question and the green box
would be the python
code so before we move on to the example
using this system let's quickly recap
right what are we doing we are starting
with a user question and then we are
just using metadata and information
about documentation to come up with the
final results and one great thing about
this is um many of us work in Industries
which are like heavily regulated and
data privacy is a huge concern so if you
have noticed we aren't actually sharing
data with any anyone else in this point
so even if let's say we we are using
open AI gp4 as our llm brain we are not
actually sharing any propriety data with
them we are just sharing the
documentation and schema and even by
just sharing that we getting pretty
accurate
results so let's uh move on from
abstract to specific and let's consider
this example so let's say we have uh
this toy database called chinuk and it
represents a fictional digital media
store where you could buy um digital
albums and Records right so we have this
ER diagram here it's um it has around
like maybe 8 to 10 tables uh with
varying levels of relationships between
them and uh let's say the US user wants
to ask a question what is the
relationship between number of tracks
versus total tracks sold per artist and
the hypothesis here behind this question
could be people who have like a lot of
tracks are they selling the most or
people who have like very limited tracks
but those are like hits and they are
selling the most number of tracks again
this is a madeup example with on a based
on a toy database so don't read too much
into it so let's see how all the the
components that we discussed before
would be used to solve this so we would
start with the data log or data catalog
connector and it will have access to all
the documentation schema for all the
tables right and the input it would be
uh the user question which is the
relationship between the number of
tracks and total tracks and based on
these two it will be able to give you
the accurate tables which which need to
be queried in order to answer this
question so from there we move on to the
query generator um it's also if you you
can think of this as a chain where um
the output of previous step uh directly
feeds into the next component so we we
stick with the question and we um add
the table names for this and query
generator is able to generate queries in
order to answer the question we move on
to database connector which is simple
just running the query and getting the
results and the last component is python
code generator where we explain that
this is the data in a python data frame
how would you plot this data to answer
the question and we get U some sort of
python
code and as I mentioned this this is how
an ideal selfservice analytics platform
would look like where the user asks a
question in plain English without a lot
of context and um the self-service
analytics platform is able to pass that
information process all these steps and
returns an output the beauty of this is
the user in a way is unaware of all the
steps taken right but it's also the
shortcoming of this system where how how
does user know how to trust this and U
we can get back to that later but um
yeah this is how the ideal system would
look
like so we have have discussed um llms
in context of self-service analytics
right so is this the long awaited silver
bullet to solve all your problems
definitely not right so what are the
limitations of this system so the the
most important limitation I would say is
dependence on data documentation and
even though we would like to have data
very well documented in almost all the
companies that I have worked I have
rarely seen data being very thoroughly
documented
so in the the accuracy of the overall
system is directly correlated with how
much documentation you have and um maybe
if you really want to build this system
first you need to work on getting the
data documentation in place and U
hopefully that will help you get started
with system the other interesting
limitation here is the accuracy right
because you are dealing with the unknown
unknowns it's difficult to predict the
accur accuracy beforehand we can once we
have this system live we can still have
users use the system and provide us some
feedback and that would give us like
some sense of accuracy of the system but
still this is a big limitation and uh we
need to sort of like work to solve
this um the slightly less important
limitation is latency right because we
have this multi-step process of calling
external apis or even if you had let's
say posted llms all this all these sort
of calls add up and when you think about
this system it wouldn't be instant it
wouldn't be you ask the question and
you'll get the results it will be more
like you ask the question you wait for 2
minutes 5 minutes depending on the size
of your data and all the intermediate
steps then you get the answer but in a
way this system is not to replace the
dashboards which are like people are
used to have having like instant Dynamic
data this is more to replace all those
ad hoc analysis requests received by a
data team right where you where you get
a slack message or an email from a
stakeholder and then you have to spend
your next two days in on that so when
you compare 2 days versus 5 minutes it
doesn't look bad but if you are
comparing it with like milliseconds to 2
minutes it looks pretty
bad and um the last and again uh very
important limitation is the nature of
this system is non-deterministic right
because llms even if you have like
temperatur zero sometimes they are not
deterministic and um the overall answers
for like semantically similar questions
could be different and this also plays
in the accuracy of the system right
where if you ask the similar questions
and are getting like different results
you you wouldn't tend to believe that
system um but I I think all these
limitations are solvable to some degrees
and it's also like if you are thinking
of it from a replacement for dashboards
or reports this is not a good good
solution but if you are looking it from
perspective of like ad hoc analysis
where they can take long they are pretty
ambiguous and many of times not exact
answer is known before I I think this is
a pretty good
system so hopefully I might have conv
convince some of you to either build a
system or get a system like this at your
job so or let's say best case scenario
you were already building something like
this how how do we improve it right so I
think uh there are some really low
fruits here which we can do to improve
the overall um overall system so the
first one is smart query retries right
and when I mentioned llms they are not
great they are not only great at
generating code but they are pretty
great at fixing the code as well so in
all the sort of query generator and
python code generator steps we could use
use intelligent retries whenever the
things fail whenever the code fails we
can pass the output return it back to
the llm and try to fix
it U the other important uh Improvement
is context so if you have context about
um what the company is or what's the
question or even the what's the date
today right so injecting all this
context in the llm calls would be great
so a simple example is let's say we bu
this system without any context and we
asked the system what are the sales for
last 30 days right and this system like
the llms they don't have any context
about what's the date today so they
might just work off on an assumption and
give you like a a totally different date
so just injecting the appropriate
context could help this
system and uh the last couple of points
are one is among along like column
profiles so some times the SQL queries
are very specific to the values you have
in columns and because you are not
sharing any actual data this could be a
limitation so coming up with sort of a
summary of um maybe low cardinality
columns where what are the unique values
how how the data is distributed would be
very helpful for llm to come up with
accurate queries and improve the
performance and U the last one sort of
targets the uh the trust building issue
so if the user is unaware of all the
steps taken they might not be willing to
trust this system blindly so maybe we
could build a component which summarizes
all these steps that we took and
provides that those summary of that
those steps to the user so user can not
only read the actual results but quickly
verify what were the steps
taken uh and from improvements we move
on to secure safety considerations so so
one of the major safety consideration in
any llm based system is prompt injection
right so if a bad actor wants the llm to
do something else there are like pretty
creative ways to do that so again I I
don't really have a good answer how to
avoid this but you should be pretty
aware of this when you're building this
system um the next one is Guard railing
the LM output so we'll be running
arbitrary code and queries on our very
real data in and it possesses inherent
risks so maybe we can get around it by
validating the queries generated in the
previous steps without providing any
context so that that would sort of like
at least C some of these attempts where
Bad actors are trying to let's say drop
your production data and uh the last one
is the database access or Access Control
lists are like pretty important for this
because it's sort of just a text box
right so people knowingly or unknowingly
might ask questions which which are
related to the data they shouldn't be
accessing and having those proper
database access controls is vital for
this um here I have some resources for
everyone so if you if you are interested
in building this or like implementing
this um at your job or you just in
Curious uh there's this uh open source
Library called Auto analyst which
implements a lot of of these things out
of the box so you can just maybe clone
the repo and like start playing with it
but if you are let's say more ambitious
and you want to start from scratch and
start building this these are like some
other libraries which are used for
creating agents or implementing rag or
Guard railing the output which would be
helpful and uh lastly I have some uh
open- Source data sets here which are
useful for benchmarking and evaluating
the performance of the system uh so that
that's all I had thank you for listening
in um I would love to take any questions
if you
[Applause]
have yeah that that's a great question
so I think one of the best things of
working with lmms is they do a lot of
heavy lifting so if you have seen like
we don't do a lot of complicated code
right it's just like calling the apis or
using some in-house llm to come up with
the code so I would say uh an ideal team
would be a combination of like software
Engineers to do to do like the backend
and front end work maybe some uh data
Engineers uh to do the data profiling
data documentation and just be more
aware of the data systems and having a
data scientist who can like at least
give you the primary metrics of what is
the accuracy of this overall system does
it sort of interact and behave as
intended and like the head counts for
all those positions would sort of like
depend on like how how big of a project
how big of a company how big of a data
set that we are dealing
with sure have you experimented with
fine tuning any of these different
components and how much additional value
if you have how much additional value
did you get out of that either in like
latency or accuracy that that's a great
question too um so I think the value in
terms of accuracy is more correlated
with the documentation than fine tuning
the llm so even if you um use like off
the shelf llm gbd4 it is pretty good at
coming up with queries if you provide
accurate description of the tables but
uh the latency is an issue right right
so and latency and cost so if you have
uh let's say cost and latency
constraints I would say that maybe you
start off with code Lama and fine tune
that on your proprietary data and that
that would give you some better
results
thanks
about service
analytics yeah that's uh that's a fair
point right so one of the metrics that I
would propose is just like the daus Maus
so how many people are actually using
this and it's a safe assumption if
people are using it they find some value
um in terms of evaluation of the actual
accuracy of the system I think that gets
a little more complicated where
initially you would have your in-house
data scientist to maybe run let's say
th000 questions or 100 questions and
manually correct that uh manually
compute the accuracy but later we could
sort of uh incorporate user feedback
like similar to what you see on open AI
right like on chat GP thumbs up thumbs
down and that would sort of give you a
good enough
estimate sure um I wonder if you can
share a general thought
of aded
mass I gu my concern is
whatever
yeah so I think um the best so what what
are people used to right like all the St
stakeholders what they do is they go to
people and ask questions so if you if
you are able to replicate that
experience from an Analytics tool I
think the adoption would be great um and
you could also sort of have um some
limitations right so if you are going to
take a huge business decision maybe you
should like do it twice right so maybe
do it with this system and then maybe
have like a Specialized or data
scientist sort of like review the word
so I think it it would be a combination
it would be something similar like human
in the loop where maybe for 90% of the
questions it's just automated you don't
even have to involve anyone but for like
high St situations we actually involve a
human yeah so you mentioned that the end
users are like the business stakeholders
um so is there have you noticed that
there's like a learning curve for them
to be able to use this kind of have to
ask the right question and they also
might need to know like how the data the
SCH SCH is like I think that is a slight
loading curve for sure but it's still I
would argue it's lesser than you using a
new dashboarding tool or using this new
semantic layer um one issue might be
when you are talking to humans you like
both the humans are on some level right
they have the the context the reality is
same for them but for such systems the
context doesn't exist so the learning
curve is providing context for example
you might ask uh what are the sales for
August and the LM might not understand
that you are talking about August 2023
and not August 2022 in terms of users
having to know the underlying uh
database or like the schema I think
that's not a problem because the whole
point of having this system is we can
like deduce information from the schema
in the
B obvious
bug
false
POS I think um the training is very
important so when you like say roll it
out to users you can first my first
advice would be like start small where
you don't roll roll it out for the
entire compan we do all the users right
and then the training of like sort of in
some ways explaining what this system
does to the users is very helpful so
even the users are littleit skeptical
right whenever they see something which
is like completely not as expected they
they can like provide you thumbs down
and like ask questions so I think it's
combination of
that next start 5
[Applause]
minutes